I have a question for you let's say that
there's a card that by most
considerations is a great fit for a deck
it's pretty powerful it meshes well with
the way the deck functions mechanically
and it improves a specific aspect of the
deck that was maybe a bit of a weak spot
before when is putting that card into
that deck the wrong choice let's take a
step back Commander as it is played by
most of his player base is a casual
format this means a lot of things to a
lot of people but the definition I'll
use here is that a deck is casual when
it is not perfectly optimal in terms of
its ability to perform tasks and win
games and when this state of being is
intentional if you are a casual EDH
player by definition there are cards in
your deck that could be switched to
different cards if you wanted to win
more games and compete with more
powerful decks this is intuitively true
to people when it comes to the cards
that most visibly contribute to that
winning the win conditions not every
deck includes the most powerful two card
infinite combos in them and even among
the ones that do not all of them run the
sort of tutor density that would help
their deck to execute said combos
consistently plenty of casual EDH
players understand that they'd prefer to
win with peros and a bunch of goblins
rather than dual Caster plus twinflame
and another segment of casual EDH
players understand that they'd prefer to
win by attacking with the aforementioned
goblins rather than dealing damage just
by having them pop into existence so
this is an area where players tend to
understand their
preferences however as you pull back
away from what shape a deck's win will
look like and dive into the functional
meat of decks things get a little hazier
you may know approximately how you enjoy
winning but do you know what forms of
resource building are most enjoyable to
you do you know the sort of interaction
suite and style of table engagement that
will give you the most satisfying game
do you know how powerful you want each
of these components to be this is likely
an overwhelming sequence of questions to
a lot of people or even a baffling
sequence of questions to some this is a
card game where you're at least in some
ACC sents trying to win games and the
natural place a lot of people end up is
finding the most powerful options out
there or at least playing with the best
options they have access to and by all
means don't let me tell you not to play
good cards I play lots of good cards
however I am also here to tell you that
there are some good cards that like a
dual Caster twinflame combo May
influence the amount of fun you have
with the game cards that may not even
necessarily have anything to do directly
with winning what you find fun about
playing your deck may be a lot more
fragile than you think much more
sensitive to the blunt instrument of an
out-of-place card or two than you'd
expect if this all sounds like it's
gearing up for a bunch of aimless good
card hate well why don't you just hear
me out for a bit this is all pretty
abstract so a couple recent examples of
this I've experienced are probably in
order quick side note I also released a
patron video recently that included some
discussion of the new bracket system and
I'll be including a portion of that at
the end of this video stick around for
that if you feel like but with that said
I want to start off with what may be a
familiar example in October of last year
I discussed my malagor deck and that one
is a Vibes deck through and through the
basic gist is that it is a deck that
pairs discard spells and small creatures
to generate card advantage to try and
force the game into a scrappy low
resource State reminiscent of a lot of
grindy 60 and 40 card gameplay a state
where my deck has an edge but typically
only a slight one a gritty game plan no
doubt and you're allowed to hate it but
I love the sorts of environments this
deck can create and I likewise enjoy the
task of grinding Advantage with a
handful of lowcost creatures within
those environments with that in mind a
useful exercise for understanding what
this deck wants is to consider two
powerful cards one that ended up in the
final deck and one that did not cxa is a
monster of a card it's an effective
discard engine that can give opponents a
whiff of the pain to come as early as
turn two and which also makes for a
killer beater that is difficult to get
rid of of it is very good at doing
everything this deck wants to be good at
making opponent's discard being
resilient and applying life total
pressure and that congruence is why it
works in the final deck despite being a
crazy good card in a low long budget
deck waste knot on the other hand is a
card that did not end up in the final
deck and that's because it is good at
things the deck is not supposed to be
good at this is a grindy midow deck
looking to plunge the game into a low
resource slug Fest best and waste notot
handing me easy resources boosts me out
of that state changing the whole dynamic
of the deck the fun part of the deck for
me is when I'm clawing for Advantage in
a scrappy game and if a two Mana
enchantment just hands me a bunch of
Advantage it shortcuts that basically
just turning my deck into a generic
impressive Stacks deck in the process
this was the example of a good card
being a bad idea that got me thinking
harder about the concept but there's a
similar and even more striking recent
example that ended up inspiring this
video in mid January I was looking at
spoilers for ether drift seeing if there
was anything new for my shirom astral
slide deck and I saw the card Monument
to Endurance on the surface this thing
is a slam dunk in a cycling deck cycled
cards get effortlessly transfigured into
resources at the rate of one per turn
allowing for an easy card Advantage
engine that can pivot into a wind
condition and which can even provide
Treasures where needed can you believe
all of that could come from a single
Magic card it's almost too good to be
true actually not almost it is too good
to be true in this case I discussed in
my video about this deck that at its
heart this is a control deck that cares
about navigating a sequence of tricky
choices about where to divert the deck's
resources do I tutor for a high-cost
artifact that gives me card advantage or
one that slows down my opponents do I
flicker an ETB creature that shuts down
a problematic spell or ability or one
that makes my board larger do I use
shum's recur ability to bring back a key
blocker or a card that pushes my own
advantage these are the sorts of choices
that make this deck a highly fun and
engaging experience for me when I'm
looking to sit down and think hard
during a game the issue with Monument to
endurance then is that it shortcuts
around this whole thing its ability
doesn't compete with anything else in
the deck and the correct First Choice
per turn will almost always be card draw
suddenly easily the most effective draw
engine in my deck isn't a multi-card
flicker based engine that I need to
piece together and then operate with
lots of decisions along the way no this
is a do thing get card engine where
taking a game action cycling in this
case is immediately and directly
rewarded with drawing cards this
simplification of value generation
decisions has a cascading effect of
simplifying my tutoring decisions it
will almost always be correct to hunt up
a one piece engine like this so my
tutoring decisions will reflect that
I'll wizard cycle for a trophy Mage to
grab my Monument to endurance because
anything else would be an irresponsible
Choice suddenly the task of gaining
Advantage has one simple route of
administration find the card that makes
my cycling cards do more cycling play it
and then the advantage makes itself
there are two other cards I exclude for
similar reasons the draw doublers Al
Hammer's archive and tfer ael's insight
are undoubtedly strong in a cycling deck
but they're Strong by shortcutting the
value generating part of the deck
allowing me to get ahead by simply
cycling rather than making use of Astral
slide and EDB creatures these generic do
thing get card synergies would suck the
identity and a lot of the interesting
decision-making out of the deck thereby
by removing a lot of what makes it fun
to me now you might assume based on what
I just said that I hate all draw that's
too generic or simple or powerful or
even that I dislike the sort of do
things get cards draw I mentioned
earlier that's not the case though I
dislike it in the case of my shom deck
specifically because it shortcuts past
what I find fun about the deck
simplifying the rich tapestry of
decisions that the deck presents me with
and rendering the more interesting forms
of value pointlessly Weak by comparison
if you find the process of building
Advantage a particularly fun one you'll
want to be careful with the cards you
add but this won't be the case for all
decks I run a bunch of these sorts of
simple strong value engines I mentioned
earlier in my R deck Beast Whisperer and
Garrick's pack leader and such like and
those feel great there if anything I
wish my draw was even more
straightforward sometimes many people
who've seen me playing this deck have
witnessed me exasperatedly resolving my
fifth ragas trigger in a turn playing as
quickly as I possibly can in order to
keep my turn length under 5 minutes
despite casting dozens of Mana worth of
spells this is because exactly how I
build Advantage isn't something I care
about there are two things I find fun
about playing this deck having a ton of
Mana which enables me to have these
intense and complex turns with intricate
ordering and figuring out how to beat
down my opponents with a big old pile of
budget bombs I do run draw in the deck
but I treat it as a means to an end with
that end being allowing me to spend my
ample mana and not end up hellbent too
much of the time in the case of this
deck what would shortcut cut the fun
would be running more powerful bombs and
finishers that allow me to convert Mana
Advantage into defeated opponents more
efficiently I like playing the role of a
final boss with this deck pumping my
volume of gameplay up to seismic
proportions before lumbering in the
direction of Victory with my large
creatures I do have ways to close out
games but they're not super fast or
sudden unless I'm at 20 or more mana and
this gives opponents a fighting chance
to claw their way back into the game and
best me in some games these big Dynamic
back and forths are some of my favorite
games with the deck and if I spent a
bunch of effort tuning the deck to win
faster I wouldn't get these sorts of
games nearly as often for a similar
example let's talk about my friend
hans's Laya undefeated slick shot deck
named is it bizit this is a control
oriented deck that plays as many
prophetic bolts as possible with
prophetic bolt as a category referring
to an is it card that can both deal
damage and draw one or more cards when I
asked Hans what he finds fun about the
deck he responded simply I like to two
for one people twice prophetic bolt in a
1v1 format is the archetypal Mana
expensive two for one card you pay five
Mana to hopefully remove a creature with
four or less toughness as well as
finding a card in the top four cards of
your library thereby generating two
cards worth of value with your one magic
the Gathering card this type of card
feels Less impactful in EDH what with
its ample value engines and two
additional opponents and such like but
allowing each of these spells to be used
in additional time suddenly makes for a
much more tempting proposition the
resulting deck looks to build values
while keeping opponent in check
gradually adding additional Mana in the
form of Mana rocks as well as occasional
amplifier permanence before trying to
overwhelm opponents with value and
gradually burn them down it was one of
these amplifier permanence that ended up
being a problem for shortcutting the fun
Thousand-Year storm see this Tech
typically keeps around a handful of
plotted is at instants that were weaved
onto an endstep holding them in Exile
until they're ready to be cast for free
on a later main phase this means that
with a minimal amount of planning a
Thousand-Year storm turn could easily
reach or more spells which could mean
that the final couple spells of the turn
are being copied several times this
won't always be an immediate game win
but it effectively nullifies value as a
concept in the deck the deck is likely
adding 10 or more cards to its hand each
turn that Thousand-Year storm is in play
and possibly digging dozens of cards
deep into its Library worse
Thousand-Year storm negates the concept
of Mana as well when a five or six cost
card can be copied half a dozen times
the progression of adding on Mana rocks
and amplifiers becomes entirely
pointless anything before the
Thousand-Year storm barely matters and
whether or not it results in an imminent
gamewin more or less comes down to a
removal check for opponents unless the
deck was Far Behind when the storm came
into play so Thousand-Year storm does
shortcut the fun in the case of this
deck by pushing the deck beyond what
it's supposed to care about getting two
for once however this isn't to say that
all powerful amplifier permanence are
off the table the new NIV Mizit printed
in foundations feels shockingly okay
here it does end up somewhat negating
the resource source of cards but Mana is
still a big limiting factor for the deck
not needing to worry nearly as much
about value does change the nature of
the deck but the deck still feels like a
version of itself and the things that
are fun about it still remain fun even
if the play pattern becomes a bit
different the same goes for the card
that ended up replacing Thousand-Year
storm swarm intelligence certainly
amplifies the next gameplay
substantially but it's still in the
realm of being reasonable the difference
between a two times amplification and a
3 to four times amplification ends up
being being a lot more tangible than
you'd expect all four of these cases
provide examples of ways to avoid
shortcutting the fun ways to experience
the enjoyable part of decks for a
greater percentage of the time you play
them through simple card Choice
decisions these probably seem simple
when I present them like this but these
are play patterns that took months or
longer to figure out and decisions that
often took trial and error to come to a
firm conclusion about in addition these
sorts of decisions might take a real
change of deck building framework for
players so what's a good place to start
for one figure out what you find fun in
decks pay attention to how you're
feeling during games when are you having
the most fun for a lot of people it
might be during the middle to later
portions of games where things are up
and running but before the deck is
actively closing things out or losing
for those people ask yourself are there
cards that might be winning your games
prematurely before your deck has spent
the expected length of time building up
to them and before you spent as much
time as you'd like savoring that part of
the game I find that avoiding a lot of
higher powerered wincons is good for
this I often run tools that allow me to
quickly eliminate a single player if I
commit hard enough but higher level
tools that will rapidly guarantee an
allout Victory should be treated with
care if you're not playing a deck that
necessarily wants to win as fast as
possible this principle goes for
accomplishing tasks as well if there are
a specific set of interactions that make
a deck fun and meaningful to you the
worst possible thing you can do is add a
different set of cards that does the
same thing better and in a less
interesting way if you have a deck that
focuses on Dungeons and the initiative
adding in a ristic study and a trouble
impairs will probably improve the deck
but suddenly you might find these
unrelated cards outshining the set of
value engines you built your whole deck
around maybe that's fine if you're
looking for raw power but if that was my
deck I'd find that a bit of a bummer for
other players the win might be the
highlight of the game if you find wins
at any cost enjoyable you should
probably go out and find your local cedh
community but for everybody else you
should ask yourself what makes wins feel
satisfying I know I enjoy winning games
when it feels earned when it feels like
I've outplayed my opponents and overcome
challenges this can be tackled from a
lot of different directions but there
are cases where avoiding cards that
accomplish tasks too efficiently can
help with this put bluntly it's really
not very hard to make an EDH deck that
wins games if you're willing to throw
the best Cards into a deck and learn how
to play them in the right order I don't
tell you to exclude good cards because I
have some sort of Vendetta against them
I tell you that doing that in some cases
might be worth considering because
running some of the less flashy tools
this game has to offer makes the game
more enjoyable more interesting more
textured for me and it also makes winds
more satisfying completing the same task
with much more Niche Hardware is a lot
of fun and can engage a lot of deck
building and gameplay muscles that just
aren't fully engaged if you're playing
with top-of-the-line materials this can
even go for decks that flirt with a more
combo oriented play style I released a
video about a $25 eggs deck in mid last
year and the main thrust of that video
was that not having access to a key Mana
engine C Clan Iron Works forced the deck
to Traverse its explosive storm game
plan in much more intentional and
dynamic ways than would be required if
it did have access to KCI playing with
weaker connecting materials and payoffs
can really bring out some more fun and
textured elements from explosive decks
which might otherwise effortlessly combo
off and win I also want to acknowledge
that putting worst cards in a deck is
hard it goes against the deck building
instincts of a lot of people and the
idea that it might be the correct choice
to produce the most fun experience might
be kind of alarming if it's not a
thought you've Tangled with before
optimization is a big piece of deck
building in a game like magic the
Gathering and I'd be a liar if I
pretended that optimization wasn't a big
piece of what informs the way I play the
game depending on who you ask I'd
probably be categorized as a spike or a
Melvin and the idea of building a
maximally effective machine for purposes
of crushing my opponents is one that
will never stop being appealing to me
but casual EDH as a form format is just
that it's a casual social format winning
can never be the only concern and to
enjoy this format long term you need to
find things that are meaningful to you
outside of crushing your opponents the
solution isn't even necessarily to
abandon the optimization Instinct but
rather to optimize for something that
isn't raw power level you can think of
it as optimizing for fun but it's going
to be easier to tackle if you identify
some more specific goal for me that's
building a deck that embodies a specific
feeling through its design a specific
Vibe but for you that might be something
different building a deck that best
utilizes dollhous of Horrors building
the most effective Turtle deck building
the most turttly deck that's still
effective whatever it is identify it and
Chase it your efforts will be rewarded
thanks for watching and thanks to
architect for supporting the channel
architect is my deck building site of
choice due to its satisfying visual
layout and well-designed category system
a link to my decks is in the description
thank you to my patrons as well for
making what I do hear possible and
here's a preview of a patron only video
I released that discussed the bracket
system I think the other reason is
because I mean they're kind of showing
their hand with the the sort of version
of EDH they want to promote here um
they're okay with a deck that has a
random infinite combo in it that might
pop off at some point um they don't want
Decks that consistently do their
infinite combos but you know the version
of EDH where you'll just have a random
infinite combo that pops off some
percentage of the time uh you know just
adding to the the kind of variance of
the game that seems to be part of the
format they're uh prescribing here um
both in you know the bracket system and
in the fact that preons have gotten
infinite combos um I don't like that
personally um it'll be interesting to
see where this goes from here but that's
just kind of my hunch for why the the
infinite combo limitations chosen are
really quite arbitrary and not very
toothful in preventing you know gameplay
I think the most generous version of the
infinite combo prescriptions you could
take is to say that uh they are trying
to gesture at the sorts of gameplay you
would want so you know you don't have
two card infinite combos in preons so
you shouldn't do anything equivalent to
playing a two card infinite combo at any
point in the game you know a fast three
card infinite combo okay you should
maybe take uh you should maybe take you
know the gesture of no two card infinite
combos to say maybe I should hold off on
that um likewise for for bracket three
um no fast two card infinite combos uh
you know they're not saying anything
about three card infinite combos but you
know maybe do something that falls in
line with no fast two card infinite
combos um that's the best I got for for
interpreting that um but yeah I think
infinite combos are a a very strange
kind of spot of this whole bracket
system